Daniel says, should you start with backlinks or only use it as, quote unquote, nitro?
What would you, what would you say, Eugene?
Would you, would you start doing them or would you see how far you can get without and then
add them?
Or what do you, what are your thoughts on that?
I mean, that's a good question because, I mean, honestly, on a lot of the niches that
I do, like a lot of the traffic really comes from the GMB itself, you know?
So like, I mean, when I, when I got started, you know, we just went through the process
A, B, and C, A, do the website, get the backlinks and then like, then worry about the GMB and
stuff, right?
So, but now it's like, honestly, like I prioritize ranking the GMB first and then I'll come back
and I'll do the backlinks, you know?
Yeah.
So I don't know.
It's a good question, but I would say this, like, this is my thoughts is, if you have
somebody that's doing them and you have your, it's systematized and everything else, like,
I would definitely just start doing them from the get-go.
I would just make it part of the process, like Eugene's talking about.
For us, we have certain things, like we build a website, then we do the, you know, I'm not
speaking in order, but let's say we build a website, then we add the content, then we
do the page title, then we do the H1, then we do the description, then we do the, let's
say we jump to the citations and then we start doing the reviews and then their next step
is we just have a backlink structure.
It's like, but you know, it's just part of the process because we know that it's going
to speed it up and eventually we're going to be able to turn off the ad.
So in my opinion, I guess by saying that, I would say I would just do it.
I would just start doing it because even if you can rank without it, it's still going
to be an insurance policy for you.